>> Laura: ONE DAY AFTER HOUSE
DEMOCRATS SENT A SUBPOENA, RUDY
GIULIANI IS MINDING HIS DEFENSE.
HE JUST HIRED WATERGATE ERA
ATTORNEY JOHN SALE, AND IS NOW
CONSIDERING FUTURE STEPS.
RUDY, WELCOME BACK.
FINISH YOUR THOUGHT, WHAT ARE
THOSE STEPS?
WE WILL GET BACK TO THAT
TIMELINE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS, THIS
IS KIND OF THE FUTURE.
I HAD A COUPLE OF TALKS WITH
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWYERS AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER TODAY,
HERE'S WHAT THEY RECOMMEND.
THAT WE SHOULD BRING A LAWSUIT
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, MAYBE EVEN
MYSELF AS A LAWYER, AGAINST THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
INDIVIDUALLY, FOR VIOLATING
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, VIOLATING
CIVIL RIGHTS.
THEY ARE DOING EXTRAORDINARY
THINGS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ARE
VIOLATING -- THERE INTERFERING
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
RIGHTS UNDER ARTICLE TWO.
THE PRESIDENT UNITED STATES
CONDUCTS A FOREIGN POLICY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE GOING TO FOREIGN
CAPITALISTS, SENATOR MURPHY WENT
AND THRIVED INTO THE OF UKRAINE
WITH NO DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT --
>> Laura: YOU WANT TO GO TO
COURT AGAINST THE HOUSE?
THEY WOULDN'T GET CONGRESSIONAL
IMMUNITY UNLESS THEY DID
IMMUNITY UNLESS THEY SID
IMMUNITY UNLESS THEY SAID IT ON
THE HOUSE FLOOR.
>> I FOUND A REALLY GOOD CASE
TODAY ABOUT A CONSPIRACY TO
VIOLATE CIVIL RIGHTS.
EXCEPT FOR WHAT THEY SAY ON THE
FLOOR, THEY ARE IS LIABLE FOR
THAT IS ANYTHING ELSE.
HOW ABOUT THE CONGRESSMAN WHO
THREATENED TO ARREST THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> Laura: LETS REMIND
EVERYONE, IN LIGHT OF WHAT YOU
JUST SAID.
WHAT MAXINE WATERS IS SAYING.
CAN WE PLAY THAT?
WHAT SHE SAID.
YES?
OH, IT'S JUST A TWEET.
SHE BASICALLY SAID THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE PUT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
WHAT?
>> THERE IS A CONGRESSMAN WHO
SET ON MAY 8TH, 2019, THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD BE
ARRESTED, THAT WAS OUTSIDE OF
CONGRESS.
SCHIFF SAID --
>> Laura: THEY WILL SAY TRUMP
SAID SO-AND-SO IS GUILTY OF
TREASON.
THERE IS THE TWEET.
ARE YOU WORRIED YOU SHOULDN'T
HAVE MENTIONED THOSE TEXTS LAST
WEEK ON THE SHOW?
ON OUR SHOW?
BECAUSE NOW THEY KNOW YOU HAVE
THEM, SO THEY SUBPOENAED YOU.
I'M GLAD YOU SHOWED US THE
TEXTS, YOU HAVE ANY MORE?
>> YEAH, I DO, MANY MORE.
>> Laura: OKAY, THERE IS
ANOTHER SUBPOENA OF.
>> I ALSO HAVE VIDEOS
>> I ALSO HAVE VIDEO RECORDINGS,
AND NOTES.
IF THIS ISN'T ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE, THERE IS NO SUCH
THING.
WE ALSO SUE THEM FOR TRYING TO
VIOLATE ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
WE CAN ALSO SUE THEM FOR DOING
THINGS LIKE OBSTRUCTION --
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
WRITING LETTERS TO ITALY AND TO
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
EVIDENCE OF CRIMINALITY
CONCERNING A SET UP AND A FRAME
UP IS OBSTRUCTING A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: RUDY, ONE OF THE
THINGS -- IT'S A NOVEL, BUT WE
NEVER SEEN CONGRESS DO ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ JUST SAID THIS
IS UNPRECEDENTED.
>> THIS WILL BE A CIVIL CASE IN
WHICH WE CAN TAKE DISCOVERY.
ALSO, WE WILL SUE SCHIFF --
>> Laura: THEY WILL HAVE TO
LAWYER UP.
YOUR TONGUE DEMOCRATS, IF YOU
ARE DOING THIS TO THE COUNTRY,
OUR ECONOMY, OUR TRADE, OUR
FOREIGN POLICY --
>> WE HAVE TO RAISE THEIR
VIOLATION OF CONSTITUTIONAL
CIVIL RIGHTS.
THIS IS WORSE THAN McCARTHY.
HOW ABOUT A TOTALLY ILLEGITIMATE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING?
>> Laura: DO YOU CONSIDER THIS
TANTAMOUNT -- WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE -- DEFINE INTERFERENCE IN
AN ELECTION?
THEY HAVE ACCUSED TRUMP WRONGLY
OF THAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS
INVESTIGATING -- BUT I WAS
INVESTIGATING NEW CRANE, WHAT
THERE IS PLENTY OF EVIDENCE, --
>> Laura: YOU HAD A BRIT, A
AUSSIE, A MALTESE.
>> INTERFERING ON BEHALF OF
HILLARY.
>> Laura: THE LIBERAL MEDIA,
THIS IS PART OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS UP AGAINST A MEDIA
THAT REFUSES -- AGGRESSIVELY
INCURIOUS ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN AND
JOE BIDEN.
WHAT THEY SAY, THIS IS
RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY.
THIS IS RUDY GIULIANI
BLATHERING.
>> GO BACK TO MY LAWSUIT,
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH THIS LAWSUIT.
>> Laura: HE IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> LET'S SUPPOSE, JUST SUPPOSE,
THAT THIS WHOLE THING --
WITCH HUNT, ARE WE CALLING --
>> Laura: IT'S ELECTION
INTERFERING.
>> THE GUY WHO PUT THE
COMPLAINT -- HE MAY BE TELLING
THE TRUTH, BUT HE MAY BE LYING.
OKAY.
SUPPOSE IT WAS A CONSPIRACY TO
DEVELOP THAT.
WITH MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THAT WOULD BE CONSPIRACY TO
VIOLATE --
>> Laura: WHEN YOU HAVE
EVIDENCE OF THAT, OR WE JUST
THROWING THAT OUT THERE?
>> I JUST SUPPOSE --
>> Laura: WE COULD SUPPOSE A
LOT OF THINGS PEERED >> THE
RIGHT TO CALL WITNESSES, THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A V
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A -
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A Y
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A U
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A R
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A A
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A I
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A E
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A ,
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A T
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A E
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A W
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A O
WHOLE PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A E
PURPOSE OF NOT GETTING A VOTE ON
IMPEACHMENT, IF THEY GOT A VOTE
ON IMPEACHMENT, THE REPUBLICANS
WOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO SUBPOENA
WITNESSES.
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO DRAG
THIS OUT.
>> THEY ARE DEPRIVING HIM OF
BASIC RIGHTS.
>> Laura: THIS IS A LEGAL
TACTIC, YOU ARE DISCUSSING A
LEGAL TACTIC WHICH I FIND
INTERESTING.
IT IS NOVEL.
BUT WE ARE IN UNCHARTED
TERRITORY.
>> HAVE YOU EVER SEEN --
>> Laura: I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING --
>> CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS -- THEY ARE TRYING
TO GET RID OF HIS GOVERNMENT AND
LAWYER, BARR, AND HIS PRIVATE
LAWYER, ME.
AND YOU KNOW WHY THEY WANT TO
GET RID OF US?
BECAUSE WE ARE EFFECTIVE.
HOW ABOUT PUTTING OUT A DEMAND
TO SILENCE ME?
>> Laura: THAT WAS TO SET YOU
OFF, THEY JUST WANTED TO SET YOU
OFF INTO A FRENZY.
YOU DON'T THINK THEY WERE JUST
PLAYING AROUND?
YOU THINK THEY ARE REALLY
THREATENING YOU?
>> I HAVE EVIDENCE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE AGREED TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: WHO?
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU YET, I'M
STILL DOING MY DISCOVERY.
>> Laura: RUDY, THEY WANT TO
SAY THIS IS A CONSPIRACY THEORY
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE, OR IT'S
BEEN LARGELY, IF NOT TOTALLY,
DEBUNKED.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
JOHN SOLOMON IS REPORTING, THEY
SAY THAT HAS BEEN BUMPED AND
WALKED BACK PEERED >> EXCEPT
IT'S TOTALLY UNTRUE.
NO ONE HAS DEBUNKED IT.
>> Laura: WHY WON'T THE MEDIA
FOCUS ON IT?
>> THEY ARE COVERING UP FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, MORE CORRUPT THAN
ANYONE REALIZES.
THEY ARE UP SERIOUS CRIMES
COMMITTED AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES BY THE BIDEN
FAMILY.
AND TAKING MILLIONS AND
MULTIMILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
PUTTING THE UNITED STATES IN A
VERY COMPROMISED POSITION.
EVERYONE IN THE UKRAINE KNEW
THAT MONEY WAS GOING TO
JOE BIDEN, AND EVERYBODY IN
CHINA KNOWS THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING THAT PRIVATE
EQUITY FUND WITH "WHITEY"
BULGER'S NEPHEW.
THEY WERE BUYING -- THE CHINESE
ARE BUYING --
>> Laura: I WANT TO TELL YOU
WHAT YOU ARE UP AGAINST WHEN YOU
GO TO CAPITOL HILL.
I WANT YOU TO DO A PREVIEW OF
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO, IF YOU
DECIDE TO TESTIFY AT ALL.
THE USE OF GIULIANI AS AN
EMISSARY TO A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
IS NOT UNPRECEDENTED, BUT IS
UNUSUAL.
WOODROW WILSON,
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT HAD
REPRESENTATIVES IN PEACE TALKS.
BUT GIULIANI WASN'T TASKED WITH
CARRYING OUT INVESTIGATIONS FOR
THE COUNTRY, BUT EFFECTIVELY
ACTING AS AN ARM OF TRUMP'S
REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S AN EXERT --
>> FIRST OF ALL, A PRIVATE
LAWYER.
SECOND, IT ASSUMES IT'S NOT IN
THE INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY TO
DIG UP CORRUPTION FROM ONE OF
THE HIGHEST --
>> Laura: YOU WERE HELPING HIS
REELECTION CAMPAIGN, OR WORKING
FOR HIM AS A PRIVATE --
>> I HEARD ABOUT THIS TWO YEARS
BEFORE THE ELECTION, WHERE
JOE BIDEN WASN'T EVEN A
CANDIDATE.
HE HADN'T ANNOUNCED.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY, IN
ORDER FOR ME TO DEFEND -- THEY
HAVE DECIDED IT'S NOT AGAINST
THE ENTRANCE OF THE